To date, a case has not been documented
in which the coronavirus
has been transmitted
to humans from surfaces
contaminated with the virus.
Still, the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention
recommends that frequently
touched surfaces
in your house should be
routinely cleaned and disinfected
to lessen the chances of transmission.
But how exactly should you disinfect
all the surfaces in your home?
First off, be sure to read
the labels of your products
to ensure correct usage and safety.
Use EPA-approved disinfectants,
and it's best to use disposable gloves.
If using reusable gloves,
be sure to use them
only while cleaning and
disinfecting for the coronavirus.
Always wash your hands immediately after
taking the gloves off.
Focus on cleaning and disinfecting
the most frequently touched
surfaces in your home.
Think tables, doorknobs, handles,
light switches, desks, toilets,
faucets, sinks, and electronics.
When it comes to electronics,
research suggests
that the virus can last a long time
on these types of surfaces.
For nonporous surfaces,
like a keyboard or a phone,
research from the National
Institutes of Health,
CDC, Princeton University, and UCLA
says that the virus could live on them
for two to three days.
The CDC suggests removing
any visible contaminant if possible.
To disinfect, you should
follow the instructions
from the manufacturer.
Apple recently updated its guidelines
for disinfecting its products.
To clean your iPhone, you can clean it
with a damp lens cloth
and then gently wipe it
with a Clorox disinfecting wipe
while avoiding getting any moisture
in any of the openings.
You can also use the wipes on your other
Apple products, such as your laptop.
If your electronics
manufacturer doesn't provide
disinfecting instructions,
the CDC suggests
using alcohol wipes or
sprays with at least
70% alcohol for touch screens.
And all surfaces should
be thoroughly dried
to avoid any pools of liquid forming.
For hard surfaces, the coronavirus appears
to last the longest on
plastic and stainless steel,
about two to three days.
If your surfaces are dirty, be sure to
first clean them with a detergent
or soap and water before you disinfect.
You can then use an EPA-approved
disinfectant on the surface.
Diluted household bleach
solutions are an option,
but make sure to follow the
manufacturer's instructions
for application. Make
sure it's not expired,
and never mix household
bleach with ammonia
or any other cleanser.
Make sure to open a window so you get
plenty of ventilation while
and after applying the bleach.
To make a bleach solution,
mix 5 tablespoons of
bleach per gallon of water
or 4 teaspoons of bleach
per quart of water.
For soft surfaces, such as carpeted floor,
rugs, and drapes, first wipe off any dirt
or contaminants you can see,
then use an approved
cleaner while following
the cleaner's manufacturer instructions.
If possible, put the items in the laundry
according to their
manufacturer instructions,
using the warmest
appropriate water setting.
Be sure to dry thoroughly.
Dirty laundry from an ill person
can be washed with other people's items.
But if you need to handle laundry
for someone who's sick,
use disposable gloves
or gloves that are dedicated to cleaning
and disinfecting for the coronavirus.
Do not shake dirty laundry.
This will minimize the possibility
of dispersing the virus through the air.
Use the warmest water setting
appropriate for your items
and make sure they're dried thoroughly.
Also, be sure to clean
and disinfect your hamper.
If possible, you should use liners
that are disposable or washable.
And, finally, clean your hands
immediately after using the gloves.
If you don't use gloves,
be sure to just wash your hands
immediately after handling the laundry.
Make sure you follow the CDC's additional
home-care guidelines on its website
when caring for a sick person.
If possible, allow a person to clean
and disinfect their own
bedroom and bathroom.
And just a reminder: Cleaning surfaces
is not a substitute for washing hands.
Experts say washing your
hands with soap and water
and avoiding touching your face
are still the best ways to
avoid contracting the virus.
So, at the very least,
keep washing those hands.